"
THIS IS THE HOME OF POSITIVE
POPULISM, PRO-WORKER,
PRO-FAMILY, PRO-COMMUNITY, AND
ESPECIALLY PRO-AMERICA.
STEVE: WOULD YOU BELIEVE IT
GETTING RIGHT TO THE HEART OF
THIS ISSUE THIS MORNING WHEN
THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND ABE
LINCOLN SAID THIS ABOUT RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE.
>> LET ME ASK THIS QUESTION.
IN YOUR ASSESSMENT WIDE IS TEN
ESCALATING WITH UKRAINE NOW?
WHY DID HE DO THIS UNDER THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION WHO
WAS NOT AS SUPPORTIVE OF NATO?
STEVE: LET'S THINK BECAUSE IN
THE REAL WORLD NOT THE FAKE PR
WORLD MOST POLITICIANS IN ALL
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE BIDEN
REGIME IN THE REAL WORLD WHAT
YOU DO IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
WHAT YOU SAY.
WHAT THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION DID BLAIR SEND
ARMS TO UKRAINE WITH THE OBAMA
BIDEN POSITION WHAT HE DID WAS
ACTUALLY STRENGTHEN NATO BY
SHAMING THEM TO SPEND MORE ON
THE FENCE AND MOST IMPORTANT A
GIVEN THAT RUSSIA BASICALLY A
GAS STATION WITH NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PRESIDENT TRUMP
MASSIVELY INCREASED OUR
LEVERAGE AGAINST RUSSIA BY
EXPANDING OUR DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION MAKING IS A NET
EXPORTER FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND MAYBE 70 YEARS.
ON TOP OF THAT TRUMP PUT
SANCTIONS ON THE PIPELINE IT
WAS A LIFELINE TO RUSSIA'S
ECONOMY GERMANY NORDSTROM TO
AND IN OTHER WORDS TRUMP
PROJECTED STRENGTH.
PUTIN TOOK NOTE HE DIDN'T TRY
ANYTHING WHEN TRUMP WAS
THERE.
NEITHER DID CHINA'S DICTATOR
PRESIDENT XI OR IRAN OR LITTLE
ROCKET MAN.
NOW LOOK WHAT BIDEN HAS
PROJECTED ONLY THE ACTUAL
SUBSTANCE ACTIONS NOT WORDS
HAS BEEN A SLOW-MOTION
SURRENDER TO VLADIMIR PUTIN ON
HIS FIRST DAY BIDEN ATTACKS
OUR ENERGY INDUSTRY BY
CANCELING THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE AND WITHIN WEEKS HE
LIFTED TRUMP SANCTIONS ON THE
PUTIN PIPELINE EVIDENCE TAKING
OFFICE HE HAS WAGED WERE WITH
THE EXTREMIST CLIMATE THAT
LETS EVEN THOUGH TRUMPS EXPAND
ON -┘- EXPANSION OF NATURAL GAS
HELP TO REDUCE OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS.
EVEN MORE LUDICROUS BY CUTTING
DOMESTIC ENERGY BIDEN HAD TO
BEG OPEC TO PUMP MORE OIL NOW
BIDEN IS TALKING TOUGH ON
PUTIN.
>> WE ARE READY TO IMPOSE
SEVERE SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA IF
IT FURTHER INVADES UKRAINE.
>> SEVERE SANCTIONS CAN
SOMEONE TELL HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION THE DAY BEFORE
BIDEN SAID THAT HIS OWN ENERGY
REGULATORS WERE IMPOSING
SEVERE SANCTIONS ON US.
MASSIVE NEW CLAMPDOWN ON LNG
PIPELINES AND EXPORTS
TERMINALS.
WE HAVE HUGE AMOUNTS OF
NATURAL GAS SITTING
UNDERGROUND AND APPELLATION WE
COULD EXPORT TO EUROPE SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO RELY ON PUTIN'S
GAS.
AND BIDEN JUST BLOCKED IT.
DO YOU THINK PUTIN DIDN'T
NOTICE?
IS NOT JUST ENERGY.
DO YOU THINK PUTIN DIDN'T
NOTICE?
IS NOT JUST ENERGY.
THE SAME DAY AS BIDEN
THREATENED SEVERE SANCTIONS ON
RUSSIA HIS OWN DEPUTY NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR WAS KICKING
RUSSIA OUT OF THE
INTERNATIONAL FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION SYSTEM STOMACH IS
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE THE
WE HAVE OTHER SEVERE MEASURES
CASE YOU WILL SEE SWIFT IN THE
WE CAN TAKE THAT OUR ALLIES
AND PARTNERS ARE READY TO TAKE
IN LOCKSTEP WITH US AND DON'T
HAVE THE SAME SPILLOVER
EFFECTS.
STEVE: THAT IS ECONOMICS
JARGON BUT THOSE HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
ELSEWHERE SO WE WILL SHUT YOU
OUT OF THE WORLD ECONOMY BUT
WE WANT BECAUSE THAT COULD
HURT US.
ABIDING PEOPLE ARE PATTING
THEMSELVES ON THE BACK WITH
THEIR BRILLIANT NEW STRATEGY
TO BEAT PUTIN AT HIS OWN GAME
OF INFORMATION WARFARE BY
DISCLOSING HIS IS IN ADVANCE.
BECAUSE TODAY'S DEMOCRATS
THREE EVERYTHING AS PR BECAUSE
WERE TO SIGNALING IS MORE
IMPORTANT THEY THINK THEY CAN
BE PUTIN WITH PATIENT AND
TRICK HIM INTO BACKING DOWN
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT SERIOUS
JAKE SULLIVAN AND BIDEN WITH
ALL OF HIS YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
HE HAS BEEN WRONG ON NEARLY
EVERY MAJOR FOREIGN-POLICY AND
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUES OVER
THE PAST FOUR DECADES BUT
GATES WORKED ALONGSIDE BIDEN
IN THE CABINET HE CAN SMELL
HIS WEAKNESS A MILE OFTEN
BIDEN CLAIMS HE HAS RALLY THE
ALLIES SO THEY WILL ALL STAND
UP TO PUTIN.
REALLY?
GUESS WHAT THE GERMANS PLEDGE
TO HELP DEFEND UKRAINE?
5000 HELMETS.
NOT GERMAN TROOPS, HELMETS.
TWO WEEKS AGO FINALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE STRATEGIC
IMPORTANCE OF THE NORDSTROM
PIPELINE, BIDEN HOSTED GERMAN
CHANCELLOR IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND BRAGGED ABOUT PERSUADING
GERMANS TO SHUT NORDSTROM DOWN
IF PUTIN MADE A MOVE.
>> IF RUSSIA INVADES, THAT
MEANS TANKS AND TROOPS
CROSSING THE BORDER OF UKRAINE
AGAIN.
THEN THERE WILL BE NO LONGER
AID OR EXTREME TWO.
WE WILL BREATHE INTO IT THE
IDEA THAT NORDSTROM TO WOULD
GO FORWARD WITH AND INVASION
BY THE RUSSIANS IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
STEVE: HE IS REALLY STRUGGLING
THERE.
BUT UNDER THE EXACT SAME PRESS
CONFERENCE STANDING NEXT TO
BIDEN REFUSING EVEN TO SAY THE
WORDS NORDSTROM.
HE WAS ASKED DIRECTLY AND
REPEATEDLY GREAT JOB THERE
RALLYING THE ALLIES AND THEN
DOES JUST RECALL THAT A
CERTAIN PRESIDENT RAISED THE
NORDSTROM ISSUE YEARS AGO.
>> WE ARE SUPPOSED TO PROTECT
YOU AGAINST RUSSIA BUT I THINK
THAT'S VERY INAPPROPRIATE AND
AS FORMER CHANCELLOR OF
GERMANY IS THE HEAD OF THE
PIPELINE.
AND ULTIMATELY GERMANY WILL
HAVE 70 PERCENT OF THE COUNTRY
CONTROLLED BY RUSSIA AND
NATURAL GAS.
SO IS THAT APPROPRIATE?
AND THEN COMPLAINING ABOUT
THIS AND NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ALLOWED TO HAPPEN.
>> EXACTLY TO SHUT DOWN
NORDSTROM THEY SAID THAT WHEN
TRUMP SAID IT WAS OH MY GOD
HOW EMBARRASSING AND HOW
UNDIPLOMATIC?
HE CAN SEE THEY ARE A JOKE AND
HAS MADE AMERICA WEAKER THAT
WEAKENING OUR DISPENSES AND
CUTTING THE MILITARY THE
HUMILIATING SURRENDER TO THE
TALIBAN AND THE BUNGLED EXIT
FROM AFGHANISTAN NONE OF THIS
HELPS AMERICA IT HURTS AMERICA
AND THIS ALSO THE IDEA THAT
RANDOM DICTATORS CAN JUST
INVADE COUNTRIES ON A WHIM TO
SEIZE RESOURCES BECAUSE OF A
TWISTED HISTORICAL OBSESSION
LIKE PRESIDENT XI AND TAIWAN
THAT'S NOT A ROW WE WANT TO
LIVE IN.
IT DOES MATTER THAT COUNTRIES
PLAY BY THE RULES OF CIVILIZED
SOCIETY PEOPLE TO AMERICA TO
UPHOLD THE VALUES OF
SELF-DETERMINATION THAT'S WHY
70 PEOPLE ADMIRE AND LOVE
AMERICA AND AS A NEW CITIZEN I
CAN TESTIFY TO THAT PERSONALLY.
MY PARENTS FLED FROM COMMUNISM
IN HUNGARY BUT MOST OF THE
FAMILY STAY BEHIND.
WHEN I WAS A KID I HEARD THE
IN HUNGARY BUT MOST OF THE
FAMILY STAY BEHIND.
DESCRIBE THE HORDE OF PEOPLE
LIKE THE RUSSIANS AND IN 1956
THE RUSSIANS DID COME CRASHING
THE PEOPLE'S REVOLUTION IN
HUNGARY.
THE RUSSIANS DID COME CRASHING
THE WEST DID NOTHING IN MY
FAMILY ALONG WITH MILLIONS OF
OTHER HUNGARIANS SUFFERED 31
YEARS OF COMMUNISM.
I'M NOT SAYING WE SHOULD GET
BOGGED DOWN IN ANOTHER WAR.
OF COURSE NOT BUT THE CHOICE
BETWEEN SENDING AMERICANS TO
DIE IN A DISTANT LAND WHILE
OUR OWN LAND IS UNDER THREAT
AND DO NOTHING OR THERE IS
ANOTHER WAY.
A BETTER WAY AND GUESS WHO HAS
FIGURED IT OUT?
THE FOREIGN-POLICY GENIUS WHO
GOT US INTO THE ENDLESS WAR
DISMISSED AS A COMPETENT
MANIAC.
TRUMP WAS THE FIRST PRESIDENT
IN DECADES NOT TO GET AMERICA
IN A NEW WAR.
LIKE REAGAN HE UNDERSTOOD THE
IDEA OF PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
AND LIKE REAGAN HE UNDERSTOOD
A STRONG COUNTRY AND MILITARY
IS BUILT ON A STRONG ECONOMY.
WATCH THIS FROM A CONVERSATION
I HAD WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
2019.
>> I WILL INVADE IF I HAVE TO
BUT ECONOMICALLY WE HAVE
CREATED A MUCH STRONGER
COUNTRY THAN WHEN I TOOK IT
OVER.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS POWER
WANT TO DO IT.
STEVE: AMERICA FIRST DOES NOT
MEAN AMERICA ALONE OR AMERICA
STAYS AT HOME.
STEVE: AMERICA FIRST DOES NOT
BUT AMERICA LEADS
ECONOMICALLY, SCIENTIFICALLY, M.
AMERICA FIRST.
AMERICAN NUMBER ONE.
AMERICA LEADS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A STRONG
PRESIDENT WHO GETS THIS AND
PROJECTS THIS, THEY DON'T NEED
TO ENGAGE IN LUDICROUS PR
GAMES AND INFORMATION WARFARE.
AGAIN WATCH PRESIDENT TRUMP
RESPOND WHEN I ASKED HIM ON
ANOTHER OCCASION ABOUT
PRESIDENT XI AND TAIWAN.
>> ISN'T CHINA LOOKING LIKE
YOU'RE GETTING MORE
BELLIGERENT TRYING TO EITHER
INVADE TAIWAN OR EFFECTIVELY
TAKE CONTROL AND IT'S
IMPORTANT INDUSTRIES WOULD YOU
LET THEM GET AWAY WITH THAT
QUICK.
>> IT'S AN END IN PLAY ON -┘-
INAPPROPRIATE PLACE TO TALK
ABOUT OTHER CHINA KNOWS WHAT I
WILL DO.
CHINA KNOWS.
STEVE: PRESIDENT XI KNEW THAT
TRUMP WOULD NOT STAND FOR ANY
AGGRESSION AND PUTIN KNEW THAT
WILL DO.
TRUMP WOULD NOT STAND FOR ANY
AGGRESSION.
IRAN AND NORTH KOREA ALL NEW
AND AMERICA WAS SAFER AS A
RESULT.
SADLY THAT IS NOT THE
SITUATION WE FACE TODAY.
TODAY WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
IS UNDERMINING ALL OF
AMERICA'S ADVANTAGES BECAUSE
HE IS TOO WEAK AND TOO FEEBLE
TO STAND UP TO THE FAR LEFT
ACTIVISTS WHO NOW RUN HIS
PARTY.
AS A RESULT, INSTEAD OF PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH, WE COULD BE
FACING WAR THROUGH WEAKNES